what is going on everybody and welcome
to part 8 of the web development in
Python with Django tutorials series in
this video we're gonna be doing is
working on the log out and log in views
and pages and all that so let's get
started so where we left off we are
actually to the point where we've
created a user and just incidentally
logged that user in because they
registered but what we need to also have
as an option is that person to be able
to log in at a later date as well as to
be able to log out so let's get to it so
the easiest thing for us to code first
would be the lock out just because it's
so simple you don't even need a view for
it so the first thing we'll do is head
to URLs dot pi and we will add another
path here and I'm gonna call this path
logout and then here we'll just say that
corresponds to views dot log out
underscore requests so and then I'll
give it a name row quick log out so we
wouldn't want to call that just that
function because this is views you know
if used up high and this is the function
name we wouldn't want to call that
logout because in Django we're gonna
literally import logout and actually I
think we've already imported it let's
let's take a peek right so same reason
why when we do login it's gonna have to
be like login request or something like
that
because if you just use that you're
gonna override that that function you
wouldn't want to do that so now what
we're gonna do is create the logout view
I think I think initially I might have
said you don't need a view my mistake if
I said a view template this is what I
meant you're not gonna need a template
anyway
logout requests because all you're gonna
use is Python logic here you don't
actually have to show the user anything
I must been thinking I just woke up
my apologies so and for the record it is
not
9:18 a.m. it's actually 718 am I'm on a
VM anyways
request continuing long long so all we
need to do when someone hits that logout
request is log them out right so first
we'll just log out then request so it
will log this user out here based on
that that we're importing so super
simple right though probably the next
thing you'd want to do is maybe alert
them to this so messages dot info and
then don't forget to pass requests and
logged out successfully and then you
could either use like JavaScript I
supposed to just dynamically Boop them
out and show that they've been logged
out or we could just return redirects
and I'm just gonna say main homepage
probably it would be nice I actually
don't know what code you would need but
surely there's like some sort of code in
all of Django to refresh current page so
be nice if you just like log them out
and then refresh that page and then if
that's a page that requires login like
what if they're viewing their account
pages a hit logout then redirect them to
a home page or something like that I
don't know anyways so here we are our
home page we've coded everything we
should need so let's go ahead and log
out Oh
logout didn't match any of them did I
screw it did I not maybe I just didn't
save I think that's all it was
let's go back
really what do I forget a comma possibly
I sure did this is what a great morning
okay now logout boom logged out
successfully and as we can see we've
it's changed to register and log in but
we hit login and gosh darn it we can't
login so that's the next thing that we
need to do so I'm just gonna come over
here we'll add path we will at login and
we will do views dot log in written
request and the name will be log in
let's add that trailing comma for it
hits me again and some people are going
to be annoyed probably by that then we
will come to views we will define login
request request okay now what do we need
to do well first of all we need to
authenticate so we've got the user
creation form the next thing that we
need is the authentication form again
for the record I feel like somewhere in
this series maybe towards the end we
need to like custom build our own form
because so far we've been able to like
import all of these forms because
they're just already these are just such
common tasks that it's already been done
but eventually you'll probably need to
know how to make your own form so
probably towards the end we'll do that
and people have been requesting a whole
bunch of other things too like Django
rest framework stuff like that that
really I don't really have a need for
that that I can tell yet for this
website but definitely something I am
curious to cover just because so many
people are asking about it anyways just
know you you can build your own forms
anyway authentication form we bring that
in so
we have that we're going to say form
equals authentication form and then
return render and we need to render
request again this I'm not going to use
the names anymore
and then the template name will be main
login dot HTML and then finally we will
have a form form is form okay so now we
need this login dot HTML which we do not
have so we're gonna go in the main I'm
just gonna copy and paste register to be
honest login let's open that up okay so
it's basically gonna be the same thing
rather than register we should say login
if you don't already have an account
register register good enough okay so
that should be good enough now what I
want us to do is do we have the URLs we
do so URLs login request points to our
views login form and logging out HTML
should be all set we should at least get
the form we still can't log in yet but
let's refresh the page sure enough we
get a username and we get password so
now what we have to do is same thing for
register we can fill out this form own
we could hit login
but nothing's gonna happen because we're
not handling for when the method is a
post request so it's just like with the
registration the bulk of the code is
gonna be involved if the method is a
post and in fact I'm gonna go ahead and
just copy that Boop
come on down here and we're gonna get
ready for the login request so if the
request method equals post we're going
to say form is again an authentication
form
with request in then request dot post
pot lovely so here request is just
always passed I don't know if I quit
stop post um I'm not really sure we
talked about this this would just be
your data though this is just so it
knows what data is like for that form
whoops
like that actually since that's a Parma
probably doesn't have spaces anyways
that's what that parameter is I think
that's pretty obvious so once we have so
we've got the form here with the
information and then if form dot and
then again is valid what we want to grab
is the username that's gonna be
something and we want to get the
password that's gonna be something
because because when someone logs in we
have to be able to authenticate that
user so here is where we're going to use
authenticate and if everything is
hunky-dory we could log them in so
coming on down here username that will
be due form dot to get Cole get Killeen
I'm sorry that's not it formed I cleaned
data yes and then the field name in this
case is username so that's kind of what
I mean right now this is kind of black
box II because you're like I don't know
what what what what I would put through
here but this is the field name so you
know if we were to open up the code for
authenticate form for example it's got
multiple fields well two username
password and so and then it has the name
of that field like if you're gonna build
that filled out in let's say HTML you
would have that name and that you would
do the same thing to get that parameter
anyways so let's username form dot
cleaned clean data we're also going to
grab the password and then we're going
to say user equals authenticate and we
want to authenticate based on
user name password then if user is not
none then we will login request user
then we'll say messages info requests
and success actually let's just take
this exact message this one thing so you
are now logged in as whatever your
username was so then we're going to
return a redirect and in fact I'm gonna
take this one again it might be
interesting to return a redirect to
whatever page they're currently on just
now they would be logged in that would
probably be a better way someone knows
what that is
I wonder if we could just like Google
that real quick like what would be the
current page get current URL Django or
maybe rip I had to get the current you I
don't want the template
I'd say that's why I figured they were
gonna have template get say redirect
redirect to current URL Django oh it's
so good I just redirect straight to I'm
curious although like there would be so
many ways you'd want to handle that
because like if there are they're
already logged in right you wouldn't
want to redirect them to the login page
and stuff like that but anyway it sounds
like you could just return a redirect
period and that will be the current page
anyway I'm gonna keep it well give it
there Bram but anyway
I don't really think about that most of
the time at least with our app you're
gonna be on on the login page or
registration page so we're gonna
redirect you the only one really would
be logout we'd almost want to like read
a read
them to that page but even logout
sentence them to that URL
you'd really only want to use that if
you were using some other authentication
methods and I'm not going to do that for
now but you could use like JavaScript to
log in and log out on any page on your
entire website and not actually need a
slash log in log out that they navigate
to anyway not worried about that right
now
else return messages dot err or so if
the user basically is none something
went wrong request and then we're just
gonna say invalid username or password
right those are the only two fields so
something went wrong so that is if oh my
gosh okay thank you Stefan for your
support that always like just scares me
anyway where was I
some messages err so anyway this is if
the if the something is wrong in the
actual forum the other thing is or
rather this is something is wrong with
the data we input now we also could
handle for if the forum itself is
invalid so maybe they didn't enter
something there whatever in that case
I'm just gonna error the exact same
thing there's really only like there's
no good reason why when someone logs in
something goes wrong other than theirs
it's something is wrong there's an
invalid username or password or maybe
someones doing something else that they
shouldn't be up to either way we'll just
return invalid username or password
that's fine okay so then we should be
all set so we actually now should have
like a login cool
yeah so let's check that let's make sure
that works okay log in to be honest with
you guys I don't even remember let's try
sent x4 and see let's see if that logs
us if we can log in on under that
account
no dict object and not call below this
is an interesting one I have have yet to
see this issue
I honestly have no idea what what we're
something in views it looks like
possibly did you do what did I mess up
Oh login request line 43 let's just head
there hmm what if I done
surely I don't have to say request
equals request I don't think that would
be required okay I see what mmm okay so
dot clean data dot get dots yet again on
any other form you would say the same
thing you would say doc get you probably
wouldn't have a dot clean data I don't
think such a thing exists when you're
grabbing form data from just typical
HTML but you could write code that would
do such a thing for you
anyway we have to get the values that
were placed in there so get and I bet we
did a dot get yeah here so my mistake I
forgot that hopefully hopefully we
didn't error out there let's just
refresh let's see if we can I don't hmm
I don't want to send the same data so
let's try sent Dex four and then we'll
put in the password oh okay
authenticate takes zero to one
positional arguments why you got to give
me such a hard time here um pretty sure
it's legitimate let's let's just try
user name equals username password
equals password refresh I'm just gonna
resubmit the form and we're logged in
fascinating okay
I wonder I'm curious to see what what
are the initial arguments there and why
that wouldn't have worked Jango
authenticates Jango authenticate
ah come on what wouldn't you hear
let's try this then I just want to see
what the initial parameters are
authenticate for that so hopefully I can
just do this authenticate hopefully I
didn't just zoom right by it
oh wait let's go how do I go back up to
this I want to read this request and
then the credentials okay so that okay I
see what same all right okay so you'll
have to give the names there that's
interesting so I wonder if you could
extend authenticate to do all kinds of
cool things for you to tell like
validate form inputs that's I suppose
that's why that's there anyway so don't
forget to say literally user name and
password okay cool so I think the how
much time I've been jibber jabbering to
you guys but I would like to do one more
thing and that is extend one of our
forms so in its like for example your I
was saying how you could create your own
form entirely or you can just kind of
change forms so for example and
oftentimes you'll probably find that
you're gonna change certain forms so for
example authentication form maybe
there's a few more things you want to
authenticate and then in user creation
form maybe there's some more fields that
you want you know that your model is
willing to accept so you want some more
fields stuff like that you can extend
forms but you can also make your own
form if you wanted so what I'm gonna do
is we're gonna oh we're gonna extend
user creation forms so the way that we
do that first of all we'll go into main
and I'm just going to copy and pick any
of these and I'm just going to call it
forms so we just need to create a form
spy so if we go into Maine and
then be blind for a moment here we have
four step but cool so I'm just gonna
delete everything here and we're gonna
start fresh so what I want to do is from
Django we're gonna import forms then
what we want to do is from Django
contrib dots auth dot forms we want to
import that user creation form that's
the one that we've been using from
Django contrib move I'm trying to decide
if we actually need yeah we do okay
jinguk contributes auth dot models we
want to import the user model so in this
case the form already exists and the
model already exists it's not our model
its Django's model that created that
they created but it's not that much
different than our own model and later
we could also just like we're extending
this form we could extend the user model
add more fields to the user model and so
on but to see all the fields for example
we could just go to slash admin here and
click on one of the users here and you
can see here I mean we've got first name
last name email address and then they've
got like some sort of groups and
permissions capability that's already
been given to users also date joined
last login ok those lots of fields
already exist here but if you wanted to
add more you could so for example one of
the things I wouldn't mind adding is
like a discord username or something
like that but like I was saying before
not really sure I would want to add that
to the user model probably would be its
own little model and just related to the
user model anyway so once we have these
things I'm gonna say class and I'm gonna
call it new user form and this will
inherit from the user creation form and
then we're gonna say there's an email
field that's gonna be forms dot email
field and then we're gonna say that is
now required equals true so the form
will not be submitted you will not be
able to register it with us
registry register without supplying an
email why would we want to do this well
we want to do this because if people
join and then later they forget their
password we need some way to help them
recover their password this is how we're
going to do it we're gonna send them an
email to help them recover it
so now class meta-model is based on a
user know user and then fields here for
this will be username email and then
password one password one and password
too
so this is exactly the same form as
before we're just injecting one more
field there which is email then define
save so when the form gets saved self
commit equals true and then user is
going to be equal to super new you new
user form self dot save commit here
false then user dot email the new thing
that we're just now adding user dot
email is gonna be equal to self dot
cleaned data whatever happened to be in
that email field there if commit we're
gonna say user dot save oops
and then when we're all done we returned
that user hopefully I did that right let
me confirm and compare for we screw
something up here so just for the record
we're committing based here like dot
save because we want to be able to use
that dot save logic that we've been
using up to this point
by default when we call dot save yes we
want to commit that data that's the real
you know SQL commit that's the real way
we save things in SQL but Django kind of
helps us abstract that away to a more
friendly term called save if we call dot
save yes we want to commit it but we
don't want to commit it at this point
we're just going to save it
then we're going to modify that email
value that up to this point we haven't
been modifying then we want to save the
user which means then we're going to
input that data into the database cool
so we've got that now we want to do is
head back on over to views and rather
than user creation form I'm gonna
actually delete user creation form from
the imports because I want to throw an
error if we try to use it anywhere and
instead what we want to do is from dot
forms we want to import that new what
was the name of that new user form yeah
new user form so now we want to use new
user form then we're just going to copy
and paste basically the replacement so
rather than user creation form paste and
then one more down here cool ok so now
let me go to our home page we're gonna
hit logout great we hit register
let's do syntax 10mm HS Kingsley at
you can put anything in there as long as
it's like a at something calm hit
register new account created send text
and cool so it looks like that account
is all set we could hit logout cool
everything's working up to this point
let's head on over to admin log into our
admin user and users let's check out
send x10 sure enough the only user with
an email address okay I think I think
that's it I think
I'm content with our users now at some
point we definitely do need to have a
recover password stuff like that we can
possibly get there at some point but now
what I want to do is head back towards
tutorials the actual functionality of
this website because that gets a little
more complicated when it comes to our
models and then we need to like right
now these tutorials are so short so the
whole tutorial could can fit on one page
it's fine but eventually that's not how
it's gonna work right we're gonna have
way too many tutorials for the front
page so then we are like okay well we
could organize by playlist well we have
too many playlists then we're like okay
okay we get organized by category okay
well a category and playlist are both
going to be their own model entirely so
now we need to figure out how to how to
kind of interact between models and all
that stuff so that starts getting kind
of hairy because that can get confusing
pretty quickly and like how do we start
actually interacting between two
different models which is really
actually two different database tables
and all that so I think a lot of people
find that to be confusing so that's the
next thing it really says the next kind
of topic that we're gonna start covering
is how can we have multiple models and
interact with them and all that so
anyways questions comments concerns
whatever feel free to leave them below
otherwise I will see you guys in the
next video